blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman so uh joe biden is getting to the
point
where he needs another major legislative
accomplishment and he needs it pretty
soon
in order to be able to justify electing
more democrats in 2022
if indeed that is what he plans to
justify as the midterm election season
gets going and i i assume that
joe biden is going to make that case
that democrats need
a bigger majority in the senate than
just 50 50 depending on kamala harris to
break votes that democrat
to break ties the democrats need a
bigger majority in the house a lead that
actually shrunk
in the 2020 election and uh it's not
exactly clear to me right now how biden
gets that legislative
victory so let's get caught up on what
we have
so far uh as a platform and
i said this before and i still continue
to say it because it's the truth as a
platform
joe biden had one of the most ambitious
uh
left-leaning policy platforms for
any president that was elected in the
history of the united states not the
most progressive
candidate ever but in terms of who was
elected biden's
policy platform that he ran on is
certainly well to the left
of president barack obama's but we are
now in the phase of looking at actions
rather than promises it is the time
where those promises are supposed to
become actions and without a doubt
uh building up the vaccination program
that was it was trash
it was what you would find on the bottom
of your shoe and scrape off as you walk
into uh your home that is what biden was
handed by donald trump when it comes to
vaccine distribution and joe biden was
able to take
essentially nothing and turn it into a
vaccination program
that it you know when we hear this term
the envy of the world
about the united states usually it's
right winger saying something that's
completely untrue
it is quite literally the envy of the
world along with a couple of other
countries
including israel and the few places that
have scaled up vaccination relatively
quickly
we have so many vaccines we're
vaccinating tourists we're giving
vaccines away to other countries that is
a major accomplishment
without question number two joe biden
signing covet relief
on early march march 11th i believe it
was
and getting those checks out to
americans with
zero republican support not with weak
republican support
not with barely any republican support
with
zero republican support not a single dem
not a single republican in the house
not a single republican in the senate
voting for that and that was a very good
thing and that bill
did other good things like um extend the
moratorium
on uh evictions and on and on and on
okay
great now what now what because
we are now 17 months from the midterm
elections i know it's crazy but it's
we're already in the pre-midterm
phase my initial thought was that
the 2022 midterms would start kind of in
mid-january is when you would really
start to see that
heat up in which case joe biden needs a
major accomplishment by the end of the
year
everybody i'm talking to uh who works
with candidates
is saying we believe this is going to
get started earlier we believe 2022 is
really going to start in the fall
by october you are going to start to see
much more activity
in terms of midterms than you normally
see at that point in time which means
what
it means joe biden needs something in
the summer
or by the end of summer but hold on a
second the house and senate are
basically off in august and they're off
most of september
uh the senate is is scheduled for five
days
in august the house is off in august and
what that means is that the last joint
day
in the house and senate is july 30th all
the way
until september 20th so really if you
need something
before the 2022 elections get going
you need something by july 30th is that
even remotely possible
at this point in time well it's possible
really only
if democrats decide we're going to do
something via budget reconciliation
and if they're going to do that
something it probably needs to be
infrastructure because some of the other
things that are being discussed
arguably it would be a debate but
arguably
can't be done via budget reconciliation
budget reconciliation
of course is a process by which you can
pass something with a
simple majority in the senate rather
than the 60 votes
that are typically required which today
because of the 50 50 split means
to get 60 you need all 50 democrats plus
10 republicans
or you need 49 democrats plus 11
republicans or 48 plus 12
all unlikely scenarios so
democrats are very much behind it's an
urgent situation right now with joe
biden and it is crept up sort of slowly
and with joe biden um over in europe
last week and and some of the previous
week and the putin summit and all these
things
the negotiations on infrastructure have
have slowed down
and the question now is what is joe
biden going to do to be able to justify
electing more democrats now there have
been tons of different ideas there's
been the tax plan there's been the
infrastructure plan you know
this idea of mayor pete is ushering in a
new era of infrastructure and it's going
to include transportation
you've got to do it though i have to
tell you as of right now
the timing seems completely wrong on
taxes i don't i don't mean i'm not
in favor of what biden has proposed what
i mean is
when i take the temperature of where the
house and senate are on balance
including democrats and republicans
i don't see the tax plan as being what
gets done if any
if anything of course i don't see the
tax plan getting done between now and
july 30th so
at this point the only
last gasp that i see as a possible
possibility as a reasonable possibility
would be pushing infrastructure through
with budget reconciliation by july 30th
and even that is seeming like a stretch
now let me say a few other things about
this there are things
biden can probably do in a much more
simple way which should be done and
could make a difference
the moratorium on evictions and
foreclosures
again there's somewhat of a debate but
biden can probably just
extend that via executive order he
absolutely should do it
uh because so many people are in the
downward pointing part of the letter k
in a k shaped recovery where the wealthy
have done very well
uh but many others have not in this
pandemic recovery that has been going on
and
we'll see if that recovery softens
because there's
some small indicators a little bit of an
uptick in unemployment claims last week
um stock market looking a little bit
soft recently but we'll we'll see
you know a lot of these are day-to-day
things we want to look at bigger trends
um
it there still needs to be more help and
so joe biden could just
it seems could just sign and extend the
eviction moratorium
uh potentially could expand extend the
enhanced unemployment if
he uh wants to do that so there are some
small victories that biden could maybe
cobble together in the absence of a big
accomplishment
but uh it is time now the the
republicans
i am this is a discussion of biden
because it's biden who's president and
it's biden who will be making the case
to elect more democrats in 2022. this is
one of the most disgusting republican
parties we've ever seen
overtly obstructionist even to a point
of being hypocritical remember when
every republican seemed fine with trump
saying
he wanted to do two trillion on
infrastructure republicans fine on
biden's covet
sorry trump's covet stimulus one
republicans loving
trump's covet stimulus too now all of a
sudden where's the money
that's typical okay i i mention it in
passing
but if you've been following politics
you know that that is always the case
so can democrats do okay in 2022
without a major biden accomplishment i
think it's really tough
can biden justify his reelection in 24
without at least
two or three major legislative
accomplishments well i
i think no but we still have a long time
until that uh becomes a reality people
want proof that their vote counts for
something
record turnout in 2020 lots of votes for
trump
and even more record votes for joe biden
people want to see things happen and
time is running out
july 30th in practice seems to me
to be the deadline for some major
legislative accomplishment it's getting
very late
uh and of course they could come in
during the break in august and september
if uh democrats decided we need to
reconvene because we have an opportunity
to do something
donald trump is preparing to be
criminally
indicted according to maggie haberman of
the new york times
during and after joe biden's summit with
russian president vladimir putin last
week
the republican right did exactly what we
predicted that they were going to do
they said joe biden is going to fail and
he was failing and he did fail
without ever actually explaining how or
why
biden failed they said joe biden has
obvious dimension we're going to get
back to that a little bit later they
said biden's not going to be able to
even speak coherently when he meets with
putin
they said trump would have done better
an obviously laughable claim
but what appears to be going on behind
the scenes according to a new report
from the new york times maggie haberman
says the true realization that trump had
as a result of that putin biden summit
was that joe biden is really the
president right now period there's no
reinstatement coming there's no nothing
trump is now reportedly preparing with
lawyers and aides for a
legal uh for a criminal indictment that
they believe may well be coming check
out this appearance by maggie haberman
from the new york times on cnn
um but also i think that it is he is
missing a level of protection
that he felt like he had when he was in
the white house some kind of
if not actual full immunity some level
of a belief that people were not going
to charge a sitting president
i think that he is talking about keeping
his political options alive because he
sees it in part as a shield against
what could be coming that's interesting
do you have
have you heard or what have you heard
about how he is specifically preparing
for this because that presents it in a
new light to me at least that what he's
doing now
is all in or at least partially in
run-up to things that he fears might
happen
look what he's doing in terms of
preparing for a possible indictment is
he is holding a lot of meetings at trump
tower there was a picture the other day
of him emerging from trump tower which i
was surprised it took that long for
somebody to see he was there
he's been there for many weeks going
back and forth between his club at
bedminster new jersey
and trump tower uh he is preparing to
describe this as a quote-unquote
political witch-hunt i think you've
heard that before and i think you will
hear
a lot of that if the prosecution moves
forward as the prosecutors have given
every signal that they're going to it is
going to be a very
familiar playbook but again i just don't
think that you can disentangle these two
things
he's taking meetings in trump tower on
the possible indictment he's meeting
with
lawyers politically he's meeting with
advisors he's meeting with his sons who
you know were running the company while
he was the president
uh he is meeting with his own attorneys
he is there this is a
a not the only focus of attention but it
is a focus of attention
now as maggie haberman points out if the
indictment comes down
the reaction will be predictable it will
be this is another witch hunt
uh they failed on russia russia russia
and they failed on my perfect ukraine
phone call and now they're coming at me
again
the reality is that these are totally
unrelated causes they are disparate
investigations they're kept being
carried out in siloed ways by completely
different
investigative entities and the reality
is trump just did a lot of stuff
that is potentially criminal trump and
republicans want to frame this
as there are so many investigations
against trump
because of the political witch hunt and
the biased nature of everything that's
been taking place
that's wrong the reality is that there
are so many investigations against trump
because in so many areas of his life
personal
campaign business presidential
administration
there are so many areas of his life that
are just riddled with potential
wrongdoing and criminality
and it's going to take years to unwind
it all also remember
some of this is taking longer because
trump successfully obstructed it
while he was president preventing the uh
tax records from being provided to the
manhattan district attorney
um preventing on the rudy giuliani side
trump loyalists at the justice
department prevented the raid on rudy
giuliani's house and
and um office from being carried out
before so a lot of this stuff is delayed
and it's going to take a while because
trump successfully delayed it
now as i've said before if this
indictment comes down
the stakes in my mind are not does trump
go to prison
i just see no chance of that people get
mad when i say it
if i'm wrong and trump does prison time
i will eat my microphone
for me the stakes are whether the
indictments torpedo trumps shot
at being king maker in 2022 and possibly
it running again
in 2024 i think those are really the
stakes here
in a republican party that still mostly
likes trump
mostly supports trump publicly could the
indictments get
so in the way that it leads to trump
being unable to run in 2024 because he
has to beat off all of these
uh legal cases now hilariously we talk
about
you know under trump the u.s looked a
lot like other countries
there are places like for example my
birth country of argentina
where you can be under investigation and
indictment
and successfully run for high-level
public office
former president christina kirchner was
charged in 2018 with bribery
and still ran and was voted vice
president
in 2019. this is classic latin american
politics while under indictment you run
and you win
could it happen in the u.s sure uh you
know after trump it would be silly to
say
x could never happen because we had a
lot of x could never happen moments
and we were wrong in the united states
but we will take it step by step and day
by day
and the latest news according to the new
york times maggie haberman is donald
trump is huddled up with his legal team
and preparing for what they expect to be
a criminal indictment coming down
against the former president of the
united states if you think things have
been nuts the last week or two
just wait until you see what happens if
and when donald trump is criminally
indicted
follow me on twitter at deepakman let me
know what you expect from trump if
indeed that that day comes
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back everybody a lot to get to
today i think
it is really time for the fbi to
act and formally start investigating if
they have not already
trumpian congressman madison cawthornes
completely
unhinged an outrageous rant about armed
citizens
taking over the u.s government and using
as an analogy
how the vietcong acted during the
vietnam war
against american troops and just every
layer of this
is trash this is a sitting congressman
he's part of this trumpian trio
lauren bobert marjorie taylor green and
him
madison cawthorne this is sort of like a
new breed of elected official
completely devoid even of a pretense of
caring about policy they just run
offices based on tweets
memes political stunts and interviews on
right-wing media
there's absolutely they're overt in that
they don't even pretend
to be about policy this political stunt
should really have some consequences
last week cawthorne who by the way
represents north carolina
i wrongly said a couple weeks ago he
represents south carolina madison
catherine representing north carolina in
the house uh was being interviewed by
newsmax host chris
salcedo now chris salcido has had me on
his radio show
you can find how that went there's a
clip on my youtube channel
and hawthorne specifically said about
those who say
that having small arms meaning firearms
wouldn't be useful in overthrowing the
government if the government were to
become tyrannical
he says no no no it is possible look at
how the viet cong
handled the united states marines and
the united states army during the
vietnam war
take a look at this you didn't see that
what i'm making allusion to but
he's asked i think it was senator
kennedy who asked him
define an assault weapon and he sat
there and said duh i i can't define
an assault weapon yet they want to take
something called an assault weapon which
you and i both know doesn't exist they
want to take it away
from us so doesn't it you know what i'm
at basically under my
go ahead yeah well you know i actually
saw him walk try and walk that back and
say well you know the definition of
assault weapons anything that shoots a
semi-automatic around something that you
don't you can pull the trigger multiple
times without having to reload
and it shoots that is basically every
single modern sporting rifle in the
united states of america but let me tell
you
the second round is not written for
sporting the second amendment is so that
the tyrannical government ever wants to
rise up
we can stop them and if anybody ever
wants to say oh well you know what uh
citizens with a few small arms fire
would never be able to stop the federal
government
i absolutely disagree ask the viet cong
how they handle the marines in the army
in vietnam
now i i really am struggling with what
is the most absurd and disgusting part
of this it's hard to figure out
because there's so much going on i mean
the whole clip is 60 seconds
he's only talking for part of it and
there's just
so much nuttiness there first of all
again
the idea of the of the second
amendment's purpose
being for the overthrow of a potentially
tyrannical government as
as the most important thing the second
amendment is meant for
that's just wrong and that's disgusting
that's number one
secondly he keeps raising the viet cong
the viet cong the viet cong
which killed endless american members of
the military during the vietnam war
he raises that as the model of armed
citizen uprising against our government
vietnam veterans are not going to like
that first and foremost but
it's most importantly a historically
really stupid analogy to make
because first of all the reason the
vietcong was as effective as it was
at killing americans was the americans
came from across the world
and were fighting in vietnam there is
simply no
analogy to a hypothetical cothorn
force of right wingers with guns trying
to fight the u.s army on u.s soil it's
such an absurd comparison
that it's hard to take seriously but
sadly
lots of the people who would be ignorant
enough to vote for this guy probably
hear it and say yeah
that makes a lot of sense and then the
other aspect of this that's absurd
is that even when fighting the us army
which had traveled across the world
remember during the vietnam war
the vietcong wasn't able to win anything
or
control anything they were able to wreak
such havoc
that they made the war really expensive
uh and difficult for the united states
to continue fighting the viet cong
wasn't even winning on their own soil
and it was their own soil after all and
the the us military was uh halfway
across the world so
it's such an ignorant and and ignorant
of history
analogy and comparison but too many
right-wingers hear this
and they think madison cawthorn he knows
history
what an amazing young man that's amazing
what a smart guy the guy's a fool
and these comments are so borderline
unhinged
it doesn't seem out of line to me that
the fbi would look at whether people are
being radicalized
and getting involved in specific actions
involving guns
as a result of the nonsense that this
guy is saying it's it's
really an indictment again another one i
mean these are exhausting it's one after
the other
it's another indictment on the
uh intelligence and understanding of how
the world works of such a huge
portion of the american electorate and
as i've said before
if you overestimate the intelligence of
the american electorate you are almost
certain to be disappointed
the biggest example of that of course is
donald trump's 2016 run for president of
the united states
one of the narratives that's been built
up by the right wing
during the biden presidency and in
particular they were they were building
this up during the lead-up to last
week's biden putin summit
was the joe biden dementia narrative
it's not a new narrative remember that
back when the 2020
democratic primary was going on
when it got down to just joe biden
versus bernie sanders
many right-wingers and even some people
on the left were saying
this is when biden falls apart this is
when
in a one-on-one debate against bernie
sanders
joe biden becomes completely unable to
put together a single coherent sentence
and it just didn't happen as we know but
they've continued to push this narrative
during the biden presidency sometimes
it's saying you know it's really kamala
harris who's running the show biden
can't do anything he's just
uh you know he's an empty suit and
someone else is controlling him
uh sometimes it's saying biden can't do
anything without notes
imagine right being prepared for
meetings that's what i call it
and every single one of these claims
that now is when it'll really become
clear biden can't even
uh he doesn't even know what day it is
um every single time
it fails to materialize but they were
pushing it again for the biden putin
summit
it didn't happen but it also didn't
happen
uh and it didn't matter that it didn't
happen because in the aftermath
they were still saying whoa did you see
biden
really concerning behavior and here is
ronnie jackson this was donald trump's
white house doctor for a while
now a congressman ronnie jackson went on
fox news and said
from what i'm seeing joe biden really
needs
a cognitive test that montreal cognitive
assessment that trump took
and then ronnie says remember trump got
a perfect score on that test and then
walks that back and says well he did
really well
yeah we submitted to that president
trump as you mentioned he did he hit a
perfect score on his cognitive test an
outstanding performance
and i i'm just saying now i'm saying
that is the new standard
the the precedent has been set and i'm
asking joe biden and his medical team
to get out there and to get this
physical exam done get this cognitive
testing done and get the results back to
the american
people we need to know that we can trust
our president now there is just
so much here to talk about uh first of
all
notice that ronnie jackson first says
trump got a perfect score
then he walked it back and said well it
was an outstanding performance
what he's referring to is when donald
trump took that montreal cognitive
assessment which is really meant to
screen out
serious dementia it's like what city are
you in
can you identify whether a drawing is a
lizard or a tiger
trump didn't get a perfect score but
even if trump did get a perfect score it
wouldn't tell us that much
you're really supposed to get a near
perfect score
unless you're seriously cognitively
struggling you give that test
to people you suspect have pretty
serious dementia
or they've suffered a stroke and you
want to evaluate how they're doing
cognitively at a high level
or maybe there's been a brain injury etc
the idea that trump's near perfect score
on that test
is now a baseline for evaluating joe
biden it's
it's all a backwards series of events
saying
trump's score was great on that so biden
should take it
is like saying i got a really good score
on a drug test well it's like no you
just weren't using drugs there was the
absence of a drug problem
the test is meant to screen out the
presence or absence of
serious cognitive issues if the new
standard
is knowing that a camel isn't a shark
and that you know we're in washington dc
then we're in real trouble
and then for a doctor to go on tv and
say
this bare bones test to rule out severe
dementia
is now the standard for the presidency
that's scary as well now let's get back
to the biden dementia stuff
i have been saying without any
hesitation
or equivocation since day one of joe
biden's 2020 candidacy joe biden
is not the same joe biden as
in 2012 when he debated and ran
circles around paul ryan joe biden's
speech has slowed down over the last
decade
joe biden is almost 80 years old i've
conceded that as if it's even really a
concession
i've also talked about how joe biden's
lifelong stutter
combined with him being nearly 80 and
just talking more slowly
now could make it seem as though maybe
he's not 100 clear in his mind all the
time i have no interest in gaslighting
it can appear that way when you combine
the slowed down speech with the stutter
but when you see biden given the
opportunity to lay out his thoughts in a
normal setting you realize that the
guy's memory easily recalls even small
details
about conversations that took place last
week and about conversations that took
place last decade
he has a full understanding of the
context of every issue he's asked about
and i have no question right now about
his ability to do the job
particularly compared to donald trump
orders of magnitude
better now is this the same guy that was
joe biden debating paul ryan in 2012 of
course not
and along the same lines if you look in
an a at
an interview at an interview uh that now
i'm having the issue
uh at an interview that trump did with
dave letterman 12 years ago
trump's facility with words his
vocabulary his entire way of speaking
has also shifted dramatically and one of
the things you notice with trump
which can be a concerning sign is his
vocabulary
is so limited compared to how he spoke
a decade or two ago in those interviews
with dave letterman and others
now if i thought joe biden was having a
real cognitive issue i would just tell
you
period i have no more interest in having
a president
with a cognitive issue than i guess any
republican
does although they seemed not as worried
about it when trump
couldn't identify that rudy giuliani was
across the table from him
or couldn't identify that his limo was
right in front of him when he got off
air force one and walked down
and had to be brought back by secret
service or when he said he wanted to get
to the oranges
of an investigation the same people now
concerned about biden weren't concerned
then
um i've called it like i've seen it all
along but to hear this from ronnie
jackson
the guy doesn't even have experience
selecting and conducting these types of
tests
he's the guy who told us trump is six
foot three and weighs 239
if you can believe that and even people
with mild dementia
can actually pass the montreal cognitive
assessment so that's the latest from
ronnie
they're continuing to push this same
thing and
i'm curious to hear from you what you
make of it are they pushing this because
they have nothing else
are they pushing it to sort of sort of
try to get back
at the concerns about the same with
donald trump i don't know
let me know what you think we'll have
more on this on the show's
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
some of you who have been watching the
show for a long time might remember the
viral
video we did many years ago called
something like to protest racism
white students banned from going on
campus or something like that
we have sort of another weird version of
this which is that
i guess to protest racism or to try to
repair from some prior racism there's an
event
forcing only white attendees to pay
and i'm going to give you my best
understanding
of what's going on here um and then
we're going to talk about it but as i
understand it this is one of these
examples of sort of like when when the
left just gets it completely wrong
this is an article from mynorthwest.com
talking about a gay pride event
in seattle that will charge only white
people admission
as a sort of reparation fee
let's read about it organizers for a
seattle gay pride event
say they're charging white people a
reparations fee to attend
they have the support of seattle city
council president and mayoral candidate
lorena gonzalez
and the seattle human rights commission
taking black pride organizers
say all are welcome to attend however
white
allies and accomplices
this is already just problematic
language this this is this is like the
worst of the worst
must pay the reparations fee it will be
charged on a sliding scale of 10 to 50
depending on one's ability to pay well
at least it's based on a sliding scale
of
economics and not like how white you are
where if like you're sort of white
it's 10 bucks but if you're really white
it's 50 bucks the event location is jimi
hendrix park owned by the city of
seattle
this raises questions about the legality
of a reparations fee
critics question whether race-based
admission fees are appropriate hint
they're not
seattle municipal code clearly prohibits
racial discrimination
but organizers have pushed back calling
criticism of their admission structure
casual violence this is my friends
the epitome of what i have pointed out
as the pro remember guys uh i'm not a
right winger okay
i'm a critic of this stuff from the left
this is the epitome of the problem
with some of this post-structuralist
post-modernist and i'm not going jordan
peterson on you guys this isn't this is
what a specific
issue of uh every narrative
is valid and any critique
can be called out as racist itself and
this is you know i've talked about
critical race theory before
i think there's lots of valuable aspects
to an understanding of the view that
critical race theory puts
forward but one of the things that's
hugely problematic is
if you disagree with any aspect of
critical race theory you are by default
a racist or a white supremacist or
whatever
even if you're just you know a hispanic
immigrant from south america
like me and this is exactly uh
an example of that that if you
uh criticize this a
structure of white people are the only
ones who have to pay to go to the event
that is a form of violence against
presumably
minorities this is gutter stuff
we solve nothing if with if this is the
the prevailing view it's not the
prevailing view
fortunately um let's look here
at uh a letter actually that was written
about uh written about this uh dear city
of seattle this is from
charlotte lefeve and philip lipson from
capitol hill pride
they say it's come to our attention that
an event called
take black pride at the jimi hendrix
public park
june 26th is charging white's only
admission as reparations
we consider this reverse discrimination
in its worst form and we feel we are
being attacked for not supporting
due to disparaging and hostile emails
please review this event's stated
admission policy as we feel it violates
seattle king county state and federal
equality laws
additionally we would like you to
investigate the event as a possible
ethics and elections violation
as take black pride is hosted by nikki
etienne
a campaign manager for nikita oliver
okay that's another issue
and the way it's uh written is
all are free to attend
however this is a black and brown queer
trans centered prioritized valued event
safety of black and brown trans and
queer folk is paramount we will make
sure their safety is prioritized at all
times great we want everybody to be safe
white allies and accomplices are welcome
to attend
but will be charged a 10 to 50 dollar
reparation
fee and given a wristband as proof of
payment
that will be used to keep this event
free of cost for black and brown and
trans queer community
but to ensure performers can be paid as
well we will never
charge admission over the color of a
person's skin
and we resent being attacked for
standing in those values so
they're kind of playing coy and saying
we're not charging admission
based on perceived race we're charging a
reparations fee based on perceived race
and by the way
we are giving a wristband what's the
point of the wristband if you're there
and you see someone you believe is white
walking around
you might wonder did they pay their
reparations
fee or did they sneak in they will be
flagged in a sense
so that as you identify people that you
believe to be white
you'll know if they paid their fee from
the wristband and you can think of some
historical analogies to such a wristband
on the basis of race i won't even
mention them okay
this is just this is absolutely crazy
okay
um forget about the logistics of
who decides if you look white enough to
be
asked whether you're white what about
light-skinned puerto ricans
what about folks from brazil
who are of mixed race but look white
what if your
albine actually had an albino uh puerto
rican friend
and uh the conversations that that he
would would end up in
the this is just the worst of the worst
of the worst
and you know i even take issue with the
term reverse discrimination much like
i've taken issue with the term
uh reverse racism if you're
discriminating on the basis of race
where you have to pay if you are
or appear to be white it's not reverse
anything it's just discrimination
um and this is the type of thing where
you know there are so many good faith
activists of
all kinds on the left with different
perspective
the perspectives there there are good
faith uh social democratic activists
there are good faith
um uh socialists uh even though i'm not
a socialist there
you know we there's all this stuff and
then this and then this
which just goes against every uh
uh true notion of what it means
to have a functioning progressive
society
and the question i always have is
uh carried to its full conclusion how
does this
solve whatever problem it is you were
trying to solve with this policy
if you disagree with me if there's
anybody in my audience who thinks this
is a good idea
let me know i want to hear from you
we've now been talking about
fox news host maria bartoromo for some
time
she has gone from being a pretty good
financial reporter
um the first woman to broadcast from the
floor of the new york stock exchange
years ago
to a total trump brown-nosing sycophant
who repeats
every bogus lie promoted by trump or the
people around him
she has promoted and signal boosted
either through guests or herself
just about every absurd lie about the
2020 election
uh and now she is defiantly telling us
she will not stop maria bartiromo
erupted
on her own show yesterday and says she
will keep telling
lies she calls it the truth about the
2020 election you just have to see this
it's a profile in what i call
ignorant courage the dynamics and the
tone is of a principle than defiant
nature where she will not be silenced
but from telling lie after lie
after lie let's take a look at this clip
let me broaden this out and by the way
dr corey we should point out the effect
that the litigious nature
of our system has on creating restraints
on drug claims that's another major
problem but but
senator this is just one of many lies
let's take a look at the biggest lies of
all
since the democrats came up with this uh
ridiculous big lie about election
integrity
these are actually the biggest lies the
russia hoax based on a made-up dossier
okay so remember the russia hoax based
on a made-up dossier
the dossier is made up in the sense that
any document is created
she's saying the substance was made up
i've seen no evidence of that
i've seen corroboration of some elements
of the dossier
and just not yet corroboration of others
but there's no evidence that it was made
up
and of course russia hoax listen dozens
of indictments
mueller unable to clear trump on
obstruction so ridiculous
to try to take down trump an impeachment
of trump with absolutely no crimes
remember that that's that's another red
herring impeachment is a political
process
it doesn't require criminality under the
law so that's a classic red herring
attached to it the hunter biden laptop
and all of his business deals and the
money that he received from
everybody from the former moscow mayor's
wife to the
chinese uh companies tied to the chinese
communist party okay so
there's there's no lie it's the right is
upset
that it didn't the the right is upset
that unsubstantiated claims about hunter
didn't derail biden's presidency but
it's it to even have it on this list
seems strange
the origins of of covert 19 a lab leak
and the tree okay and then of course and
then she says
uh so notice she says as a as in passing
that there's been a lie about the fact
that covid was a lab leak
we we don't know that to be true and i
like many others have said
investigate everything but let's not say
something is likely until we have reason
to believe that
by treatment i assume she's referring to
hydroxychloroquine and of course the lie
there was
was from the right of course there's the
armed insurrection
armed insurrection is what nancy pelosi
keeps calling january 6
senator how many guns were actually
taken
up on that day okay there were some guns
we know that there were some guns
since she says it was armed well by the
way
they they always talk about thousands of
armed insurrectionists
i asked the eyewitness not one not one
gun was recovered either in the capitol
or on the capitol grounds understand
that recover just means they weren't
left behind
according to that fbi witness so but
there's video of people with with
handguns that's just
one of the latest big lies um
and you know maria do we have to
understand how dangerous this is for our
democracy
everybody's concerned about her show is
dangerous for democracy russian
interference the
2016 2020 election what the big media
does uh
it is so much more influential and
interfering in our election in our
electoral process than anything
that right so johnson's filibustering
but now listen to what she says when
they go back to maria
or china could ever hope to accomplish
and and they don't admit it they'll
never admit it
i am so incredibly proud of this team
on sunday morning futures and of working
alongside
you we have been telling every story
we've been on the right side of it
for seven years going i've been trashed
every day along the way keep trashing me
i'll keep telling the truth
a defiant and principled maria bartoromo
who has not been on the right side of
even a single issue that i can remember
and uh telling us that she will keep
telling
all of the lies what's the long game
for maria bartoromo is it that trump
comes back
because while he was president i'm sure
it was very cushy and fun for her to
have a uh
a friendly president that she could
access
but what is the long game at this point
in time i have no idea
let me know if you have thoughts make
sure you're subscribed to the second
youtube channel youtube.com slash
pacman live new youtube channel
with totally different content we'll
take a quick break
and be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show
so we have another signal about this
internal battle taking place
between the pro and the anti-trump wings
of the republican party
and uh it seems very clear that the
pro-trump wing is hugely winning now in
the next segment i'm going to talk about
a poll many of you emailed me about
saying look at this one poll david it
shows trump is not winning
we'll get to that uh i believe when you
look at the totality of the evidence
this is still a very very trumpian
republican party
and what we're going to look at first
here is that former uh trump vice
president mike pence
was brutally booed and heckled at the
faith and freedom coalition a few days
ago by fellow trumpists mind you
now how wild is it that at this point
mike pence who was simply a plant that
trump could do whatever he wanted to do
trump could water pence or not or weed
him
or pull off the flowers the guy was like
an immobile plant in the back of the
room barely sentient during the trump
administration
pence is now widely seen as not trumpian
enough
because he didn't i guess try to steal
the election on january 6th for donald
trump via some mechanism that is still
not completely clear to me
and now mike pence is suffering the
brunt of it his career may be over
or at least dead for several years until
he can maybe rehabilitate it
check out this video of mike pence being
called a traitor and heckled brutally
mercilessly during his attempted speech
just interruption after interruption
it is great to be back with so many
patriots
dedicated to faith and freedom
and the road to the majority
[Music]
and i want to thank my friend ralph reed
for those overly generous words
i'm deeply humbled by them
ralph reed knows me well enough to know
the introduction i prefer is a little
bit shorter
i'm a christian a conservative and a
republican
in that order and i am honored to stand
before you today
there's talk of pence 2024 but if the
guy can't even get a sentence out
about i'm a christian patriot in front
of a right-wing audience
without being heckled by that very
audience it's not looking good for mike
pence
for 2024 and understand that he's being
called a traitor
because he didn't overtly try to violate
the constitution on january 6. the
people who claim to be all about the
constitution
are mad at pence because he didn't find
some way around the constitution
to install trump for a second term he
didn't win he still did trump's bidding
for four years
he stood there he nodded along he
flattered trump he said
thanks to trump we did this we did that
even though it was all bs particularly
around the pandemic
and he just didn't openly try to get
around the constitution on january 6th
and now the guy's a traitor that can't
get a sentence out
now we know what pence's strategy was i
don't feel bad for pence
pence's strategy was bite his tongue
stay quiet
stay on trump's good side so that then
he could try to appropriate trump
appropriate trump's base for himself
whenever trump's done be it 2024 or
whatever the case may be
it all went in the trash with what
you could say with one act it's really a
non-act
pence abstained from trying to openly
circumvent and destroy the constitution
on january 6th
and pence is now an enemy to trumpists
plain and simple he was a good boy for
three years 11 months and two weeks
but with just two weeks left before the
end of the term
he said sir i can't steal the election
and now the guy can't get a single
sentence out
in front of a supposedly friendly
audience
it is quite stunning and i don't feel
bad for the guy
it's just amazing how reactionary and
rabid that trump base is
pence made his bed at trump's as trump's
vp and he's going to have to sleep in it
now but
a stunning series of events and also i
mean at this point
what is going on in pence's mind that he
even continues to stand up in front of
these crowds like even
religious right-wing crowds which are i
guess is bread and butter
these are the same people some of whom
wanted him dead on january 6. remember
some of these very people
are part of the political movement that
was calling for pence to be hanged
hang mike pence was their chant on
january 6th
why even subject himself to it at this
point
i guess at least this crowd wasn't
chanting hang mike pence at this
particular event
but i see pence's political career as
completely dead
for a while let me know if you disagree
and speaking of the future of people's
political careers
let's talk about that next i got a ton
of emails from people saying
david there is a new straw poll out
for republicans in 2024 and
trump isn't winning you've got to talk
about it so i'm going to talk about it
but
for better or worse i don't know if this
will bring pleasure or disdain or
sadness to people in the audience it's a
pretty meaningless poll
this is a poll from the western
conservative
summit and indeed republican florida
governor ron desantis
won over donald trump in this
straw poll that was conducted on
saturday
now let's look at the numbers this is a
poll
in which ron desantis came in first with
74 percent
donald trump was second with 71
then you have ted cruz at 42 mike pompeo
at 39 percent
and tim scott at 35 now why is this a
meaningless
poll result it's meaningless because
this is
number one it's a long time from now
first of all number two
this is an approval poll so there are
two things that make it meaningless
for us for identifying trump's actual
chances
in 2024 number one it just asks you
do you approve of trump desantis whoever
not do you support them in 2024 as the
republican nominee
and number two you can vote uh yes
essentially i approve
for more than one person that's why it
doesn't add up to 100 desantis 74
trump 71. so this tells us
very very little about what's going to
go on in 2024
but i still think that there are some
interesting things to glean
from this why is it that desantis is
doing well
desantis is doing well because he is a
more
competent and i believe far more
dangerous version
of trump's authoritarian lunacy in a
sense desantis
is more trumpian than trump to the
degree that he can better communicate
his hair brained ideas that he shares
with donald trump himself we've talked
before about
you know could donald trump's presidency
open the door to an even dumber and
even more incompetent version of trump
that republicans would vote for the
answer is
absolutely uh as i've said earlier and
before
if you overstate the intelligence of the
republican electorate you will be
disappointed
we thought in 2015-2016 okay there's a
lot of ignorant republicans who are
easily tricked
but they're not going to vote for trump
they're not this ignorant and then they
did
so could they vote for someone even
worse than trump
in terms of cartoonish incompetence yes
but the risk about desantis is that he's
more competent than donald trump he's an
authoritarian nut
with delusions based on supply-side
economic ideas and
religious conservatism and all this
stuff but he is more
competent than trump he is more coherent
in the presentation of these bad ideas
and that has the potential
to make him far more dangerous than
donald trump actually is and that's a
really
really scary thing so on the one hand
it's an approval poll you can say i
approve of desantis
and i approve of trump um and
so that makes it of limited value to us
right now for 2024
it's also approval rather than who would
you vote for
it's also still the first half of 2021
so there are limited things we can glean
from this but if i am to glean
one thing here it's that donald trump's
worst uh instincts are present
in ron desantis and packaged more
competently
in terms of desantis's delivery and
quite frankly
desantis being from florida florida we
don't know what the map
is going to look like in 2024 a lot of
it will depend on how does 2022 go and
how much voter suppression is there and
many other things
but there is no doubt that if florida
is important desantis as the republican
nominee
could play a very very big role there as
well so
don't read too much into this but an
interesting straw poll nonetheless
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219
to david p here is a caller
with a financial question trying to
safeguard their friend let's take a
listen to this and then we'll talk about
it
hi david this is angie from milwaukee i
have a friend
he's 34 and is from ghana
he's been in america two years and wants
to save for a house
beautiful his idea was to put all kinds
of money in his 401k and when he had
enough
take it out and use that money as a down
payment
i tried to explain to him that's a bad
idea
because he would pay a lot in taxes and
penalties
i'm wondering other than a standard
savings account
would you recommend something else so
listen your instincts are completely
correct
this is not a financial advice show
every
everybody's individual situation should
be reviewed with
you know a financial advisor you trust
ideally a fee only financial advisor but
i do have some background in this i do
have a master's degree in financial
planning and
and so here's my thought on using a 401k
for a down payment
uh there's a lot of reasons not to do it
you will owe income tax on the
withdrawal
um you may even if it puts you into the
next tax bracket you may even
end up paying more tax on that than you
pay
on income remember it's a marginal tax
rate if you're younger than 59 and a
half
you will owe a 10 penalty on the money
that you would draw
you can never repay the account and so
you lose years of
tax-free earnings which is the whole
point of a 401k
so i would not go in that direction
there's also the possibility of
borrowing against the 401k
now there were some special provisions
done um
around covid on withdrawals i don't know
about
i'm talking about in a non-code
situation you can borrow up to 50
000 or half the value of the account
whichever is less from your 401k
if you are using it to purchase a house
but you've got to repay that loan
usually within five years if you leave
the job you've got to repay it
there's a bunch of reasons not to do it
so generally speaking and this is not
personalized advice
do not use time in the market right
leave the money in the 401k if you want
something better than a savings account
for saving for the down payment in the
short term
if you're talking about years you could
look at
extremely low cost index funds now there
is risk with those the money
the the they can lose value if the
market if you've got a four-year time
horizon before you want to do the down
payment
over four years the market could well
lose value um
but then you're avoiding a penalty and
uh you would just pay capital gains on
the gains
there so not specifically tailored to
anybody but
i would be really hesitant to take money
out of a 401k
for a house down payment i would try to
plan ahead and think about
uh using a different vehicle if that's
the goal all right just
i don't need i i don't know why people
are even calling me with these questions
but
i i feel comfortable talking about it
always
check with a financial advisor we have a
great bonus show today
we will talk about the communion
abortion controversy
with joe biden we will talk about texas
governor greg abbott
announcing a down payment on a border
wall what we're back at this
you've got to hear what's going on it's
bonkers and we will also talk about
remember that guy
ammon bundy the anti-government militant
who led the armed takeover of a u.s
wildlife refuge
that guy is now running for governor in
idaho
we will talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com and we'll see you on
the bonus show today
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman